sur le parvis tout autour de l'autel sur
le visage des célébrants l'église
catholique de saint stéphane ne fait pas
dans la discrétion
musique pop rock drapeau arc-en-ciel
omniprésent le ton est donné et l'appel
est explicite et vous soyez hétéros gays
ou autres nous allons bénir votre union
sein d'églises
qu importe ce qu'en pense le vatican une
petite révolte
matteo et max de fervents catholiques
sont venus entourés de leurs proches et
amis pour faire bénir leur couple un
symbole important de leur engagement
sabine et bianca elles ont grandi dans
la foi protestante
depuis quatre ans le couple pu
légalement se marier civilement en
allemagne et adopter des enfants
mais cette cérémonie apportent à leur
union une dimension sacrée qui leur
manquaient pas le match là c'est loin
d'être le cas à rome en mars le vatican
a publié une note dans laquelle il
réaffirme qu'il considère
l'homosexualité comme un choix et un
péché la congrégation pour la doctrine
de la foi confirmait aussi
l'impossibilité pour les couples de même
sexe de recevoir le sacrement du mariage
avec mon sac
une déception d'autant plus amère pour
le jeune prêtre qui dirige aussi une
maison de jeunes que le pape françois a
donné son assentiment la déclaration de
la congrégation
une trahison des valeurs d'inclusion que
johannes porte tous les jours dans son
travail auprès des jeunes engagés ils
étaient au premier rang lors du défilé
de la fierté lgbt qu l'effet douche
froide entraîné une riposte immédiate en
allemagne lui et quelques deux mille six
cents prêtres ont signé une pétition
pour dénoncer la position du vatican
dans la foulée de cette fronde plus
d'une centaine d'églises ont commencé à
organiser des bénédictions public pour
les couples homosexuels chauffage par
[Musique]
l'église catholique allemande a perdu
deux millions de fidèles ces dix
dernières années
secoué par de nombreuses révélations de
scandales d'abus sexuels de mineurs et
le pen se réformer en gros ce film elle
incarne cet épisode c'est aussi l'église
de max et de matteo une église qui a
bercé leur enfance et qui transpire dans
tous les recoins de l'appartement que le
jeune couple partage
la foi en dieu mais aussi la fois
qu'avec encore un peu de patience
l'être humain sera triompher des
institutions et que comme le vu le
slogan de la rébellion des prêtres ici
que l'amour n'en portera